>>> TONIGHT WEMORE ABOUT THCRUCE
LIINE U.S. AND
FOUND AT THE SCENENNECTION TO R
EA LEARNING THAT2022 BENTLEYUP
ENTERED FROM THE U.S. SIDE AND
WAS INVOLVED IN THAT C.RVGOING K
HE HOU B HAD CTE IN STOP ONE
NETWORK FROM LINKING ITO SSIBLET
T I'VE BN TOLD
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPTED TERRORISCT
AFTER THAT LARGEXP
PACKED THAT CAR  O
PL
AS FOR WHA.
T KNOW HOW LONG E
PEOPLE WHO PERPEEDS
ATTACK HAVE BEEN IN THIS
D THEY COME INTO THE COUNT
LEGALLY?
DID THEYROSS
AND CLM ASYLUM?
WERE THEY SOME OF THE NEARLY 1M
INTO THIS CO MOSHESE
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS, T
GEN-Z.
K ATHA
SOPHISTICATED.OK, TH
ITOU INSPIRED. EASTO
HOW TO DO THIS ONLINE, UNFORTOI
>>EACHED?SA TERROR A CONNT PEOPS
I
REPORTING.THIS WAS RECKLESS
BYNTS, IT WA
INACCURATE
HE T ATTACK.
TH NX
INRTED AS. TO VEOU OF
HOW THEY REPORTED THIS
THE AFTERNOON.
A PUSH ALERT T
THE MOBILENES.LE WITTHE MOBILE
ITD YORK VEHIC
PLN ATTE
ATTHEY PLAST FRONT
PAGE OF THEIR GH TRAFFICKED ITE.
X IS A VERY HI
JS ONE.
A WORDF
WERE B O PEOPL
INACTE REPORT. FOX NEWS S
EIRYONE ELSE
A TION
THEY HAVE NOT ACTU ISSUE
THEY QUIETLY EDITED OUT
R GI
ES
THE
WALKED BACK
THE REPORTINWHILE
BLAMING HER
RESPONSIR
DAYS IN FACTS., ABBY,EAL CRLERGS
WHEN YOU M YOUE
ANT, FOX IS NOT DOING A E AND
THEY'RE RELYG FROM
>> AND IT PENETRATED EVE
PEOPLE LIKEY CLAIMOULD BE TERRO
MEDIA.
THAT WASROTOO.
L IMPACT.
S DEFI.
'S ALLTHE TWEETS ABOUT BORR AN
POSSIB TATTACKS,HOSE
ARE STN HIAND HE'S THE GUY WHO O
CARES ABOUT
TRUTHFUL WHY HASN' CLARIFIEDX W
C TERRORISM ON THE AIR.
THIS WAS NOT SMALL MISTAKE. HUGK
IFENINUS
NEWSF "THE NEW IMES"  CNN MADE
THIS.YBE LOSTHR JOBS OVE
IGHT WIN
SPACE, THERE'S LITTLE
AC AY WR